quant à écouter je ne vous cache pas que
je suis très très heureux et très honoré
d'être la part du coup ce soir dans
cette soirée x et quand j'interviens
départ thibault je me suis dit on se
connaît à peine de la fin de soirée mais
je me souviens que j'étais assis près la
composition et à l'âge des cours j'ai
l'impression que je suis pas content à
flers accord en fait par rapport à ce
que j'imaginais de la saulaie est bon on
va te réveiller s'arranger donc le sujet
que je vais causer c'est ça avec la
visite hip hop et il s'entoure dont
l'horloge tourne
j'aurais dû dès qu'il était aussi un
problème déjà soirée mix nantes
cela s'est réglé en loge tour donc en
fait parce que la plage de l'horloge à
nîmes
s'il ya bien quelque chose qui bouge pas
doug lepard et qui est l'occasion d'un
vraiment du goût au moment et à
l'endroit c'est non en fait j'ai compris
en fait que thibaut de beck prêtre est
troublé par pour sex-appeal était déjà
sur altran machin est en fait il faut le
dire par l'horloge 12 mai leurs atouts
c'est ça la vérité se cache pas des
plateformes plus monter la lumière donc
ça veut ce que je vais essayer cause et
si vous voulez bien comme ça pendant les
16 minutes 20 qui brest réfléchir un peu
avec vous sur cela que parfois proche de
la galère parce que le tout
là encore nous échappent dans l'eau
coule comme ça il y avait un philosophe
de l'antiquité extraits et la cuite
comme ça et soit il disait si on a su
représenter le temps c'est comme un
enfant sur cinquante mille enfants
élèves il est souvent comme ça amuse
aussi hors du temps y est tu en as cool
quoi pense un peu confuse que je raconte
que je démarre un mérité l'or là il ya
quelque chose qui est de l'ordre de
quelque chose qui nous échappe
voyez faut bien une mauvaise dollar
un jeu comme il ya un philosophe fabien
dit des choses là dessus c'est un mec
qui s'appelle sénèque savons que vous
lui sied c'est qu'en général le
philosophe fruits lisible lui ne l'est
pas et il a écrit un fort petit bouquin
alors ça c'est papy tweet abords des
girafes de réussir à une forte petit
bouquin qui s'appelle de la brutalité de
la fille et le au moins un mouvement pas
sur la marchandise parce qu'enfin le
temps que lui qui en fait c'est un temps
assez vague
il est relativement court et dense guga
et il ajoute suivante il dit la chose
suivante serait qu'un jeune qui arrange
la copier parce que le projet du reste
un petit pot 26 la maison ne tourne pas
et bâti ce soit toi et moi sautera pas
plomber
en les choses à jouer dans leur petit
comité
et voilà ce que dit ce nectar de la vie
reste est de la ville où dix les hommes
se plaignent de la brièveté de la vie
mais il pèse peu de temps dont ils
disposent parce qu'ils ne vivent pas dit
cette phrase magnifique
la vie ne se mesure pas avec une horloge
d'une distance
elle se mesure à son ami cité à sa
qualité
quelle que soit la priorité de notre vie
nous ne manquons pas de temps mais nous
perdons notre temps nous le dépensons
pure perte à des occupations
parfaitement faire dépenser entre temps
à des occupations parfaitement l on
prétend mort de temps mais la vérité
c'est pas comme en dedans la vérité
c'est que on gaspille on le perd et même
les robes d'affaires à vous pour ça elle
fait ça vaut la peine de commencer par
cette histoire
le mobile utilisé les romains et disait
sénèque au tube 1,9 au tube n'est bochum
savez mes gosses et toi vous y avez la
main jean prat la négoce était parti en
on gagne ça l'a fait le voyage
bon ba et ba le négoce ce poids est là
dessus les les lavages et romain sur
france inter le kop je consacre au
négoce est un temps que je sacrifie que
je détruis que je vous dise
d'ailleurs le cornec ojos nec aux sioux
ça vient de racine leetch qui est
négatif je détruis jeu prise je ne
trouve pas ça donnait par exemple cette
ligue est le nexavar pense mais je me
décris un truc comme ça comme take
suffixe négatif privatif et aux tubes et
aux sioux savez ans en france est très
éloignée mais ce n'est le loisir c'est
le manque du prends ton temps et ça
c'est vachement intéressant commencer
par ça i'm happy soup est au coeur parce
que je prétends pas si jésus merci mon
pote
elle est le mec au succès pouvoir en
fait c'est le moment où tu pue ça gâche
content cette maman veut tout à faire le
mec il est dans les affaires le mec il
est dans le business le bec par exemple
celle d affronter un x y ou des vans et
tu vois vraiment bien géré le public
avec des temps rapides tant que frère
tu vois ça mais quelle superbe géré par
cette affaire enfin cette affaire
supercherie mais ce que nous décidons
hacker là vous aviez très intéressant
pour nous il saute dans le dos de la
firme qui sautent dans l'otan des
affaires qui sortent donc dans ce
business
ils sont d'autant plus tape taupe qui
sauf dans quand vous apprenez président
dix engins n'ont même pas 40 ans quand
je rentre plat du pied ce type il faut
gérer la france comme une grosse affaire
et bah en fait tous les coups frotter à
quelques jours du 8 verres on est
confronté à un univers dans des
critiques les gens précarisés mes
engagements professionnels
les gens maintenant tenir les
engagements économiques les gens
prétendent qu'ils sont des grandes
ambitions est en fait destinée
caractérise du fui le temps ils ont une
peur panique
parra hors route et alors définitive
toutes ces stratégies qui sont la
négociation toutes ces stratégies qui
sont au fond le monde de l'économie et
va le monde économique
il arme à des mouvements qui sont
rationnels mais le montrent les plus
vite le monde des affaires le monde mais
les passes ou fondement c'est toi c'est
l'accord panique devant le temps qui
passe et en fait les gens se jettent à
corps perdu dans un projet nommé car des
projets politiques pourquoi parce que
toi je suis dans le projet où je suis je
suis pas là et oui c'est la scène
présent donc l'instant vécu je ne savons
pas et je ne savons pas parce que je me
projette pas ce que j'ai en mission
parce que je veux un retour sur
investissement est connu que j'ai pas
sûr évolué retour sur investissement
parce que je me suis fait piquer par là
parce que notre frenchie moi je ne cache
pas que jaja date du combat
et qu'est ce que je vais je suis dans le
regret la revanche fois je vous ai
indiqué avant tout le tard le temps je
suis dans le regret est ce que je suis
je pas dans l'instant présent je suis
pas dans ça vous m'en suis pas du tout à
ce qui se passe et ce qui se passe
l'instant vécu fugitif que j'aurais dû
saisir
tu comprends ça comme ça car je crois
quand même que je m'appelle quand il
s'est passé cette fois-ci justice hurle
on a d'une part pour sa cinquième et
donc mon ami comme ça ces mecs j'ai
souvent parlé de lui vous allez avoir la
place du coq j'oublie mes reviendra
sénèque 1 europa donc s'il vous plaît
est intéressé il ya eu une espèce de ma
la vie sociale et cette maladie sociale
très vite elle est bâtie cette maladie
parcours font les hommes et lui
d'assumer leur existence propre
et il se jette dans les affaires n'ont
pas de motifs rationnels lorraine m donc
en gros dés motifs de calcul est bon des
motifs qui sur l'état physique et quel
est le motif pépins physiques de base
c'est qu'en fait ils vivent comme s'ils
s'étaient était
saisissez ça il mais qu'en fait languir
sociale leur mission économique au
l'ambition politique qui les travaillent
ou font de même
c'est un ressort métaphysique et le
reste leur ressort métaphysique
c'est qu'ils s'imaginent ne jamais
mourir et comme ils s'imaginent ne va
pas mourir
ils ne profitent pas de l'instant car il
estime que l'instant tout va se répéter
à jamais et c'est la raison pour
laquelle alors ils négligent l'instant
et il se projette où ils sont dans les
rues de la revanche et la taz ici
faisait d'un kata sienne marca passe
quelque dix ans définitif de ceux là qui
veulent la toute-puissante cela qui
donne la toute-puissance économique cela
qui est bonne la puissance politique
cela qu'ils veulent la de puissance dans
les affaires sont d'abord ceux là qui
n'ont pas compris qu'ils sont marqués au
sceau de la précarité
ils sont marqués au sceau de la voir ils
sont rares bureaux souffre d'une prière
s'il osait comprendre que la vie est
brève
le bouquin de ces règles et qu'elle vous
parle c'est de là qu'ils prennent s'ils
osaient comprendre que la vie est vrai
qu'ils ont osé comprendre qu'ils sont
mortels alors ils recevaient assez
hormis sur le doute puissance et pouvait
enfin savourer l'instant vécu car ça
vaut bien la sq ont vécu qu'à la
condition qu'on sache il est unique et
pour savoir qu'il est unique il faut
savoir par terre je vis ça
voilà c'est pas mal et donc ça veut dire
que plus le mec en fait tu réussis au
niveau du pouvoir qu'ils soient
économiques politiques fenêtre une
religion définitive
le mec il en être propriétaires vont
revenir et pas compris yater de son
existence parce qu'ils ne pourront donc
parlé du fait de son existence
électrique air qui fuit sa vie se
réfugie dans une ville morte à l'ined
pacotille et dans une toute puissance
qui s'appelle le monde des affaires
ça va je n'ai autrement quiconque voit
un haut poste dans cette société
témoigne par là d'une autre pathologie
mentale
ils applaudissent et vous applaudissez
pétrolière et qui sont votées et
emportant vous êtes complice la maladie
mentale des mecs en question d'oublier
leurs services arrêt c'est un peu ça
j'appelle à l autre ambitionnait qui
continue et qu'est ce qui nous dit c'est
vrai qu'il nous dit l'intrus qu'il faut
faire c'est faire en sorte que l'eau
guérissent les hommes de l'illusion leur
immortalité et qu'on leur apprenne à
mourir alors vous connaissez le topo et
les hommes apprennent à mourir trop
semblable à qui traînent répondu dans la
philosophie un jeu accessible comme il
l'a raconté tout du plateau parce que
plate c'est déjà un coup de mou tout à
fait légitime en élite et ça c'est la
philosophie c'est avant la crise mais
qui paraît que si on savait par contre
ils savent être pris comme sénèque et
alors on dirait ce super sur la nouvelle
à conscientiser le fait est bon pour la
mort on pourrait savourer l'instant elle
finirait alors avec nous s'ils sont
vicieux qui surtout jamais sauf que le
robert ya même deux problèmes pour leur
7e reste trois minutes
deuxième problème c'est quoi la foule
dense est clair un domicile ce code qui
perce la défense ou par rêve à couvrant
que la mort les menaces et tous les
pareil peut-être le flash ball qui sont
d'un gros risques professionnels ne peut
dire quand même que la philo c'est du
pipeau
[Musique]
sans risque je veux dire par là il n'est
pas certain qu'on puisse se persuader
des mortels c'est une très belle phase
avec sa pelle jankélévitch gens se
fassent entre nos mains même
jankélévitch unis comme ça et nous nous
savons tous mortels cette fois plus
longtemps pour se connaître en faire pas
faux on y apparaît au début tu as joué
toute la vérité la vérité c'est que tu
es une fille tous comme des immortels
simplement la vérité je suis tous comme
si on allait jamais mobile donc ce n'est
qu'il avoue nous rajouter près parfois à
la mort
très vite le mari s'appelle la mort
comme disait l'attaquant nikita thurman
euros l'attaquant belge a déjà loupé à
jal une très belle phrase d'un mec ça
pulse choc est survenu là je suis mort
de cette phase de leur maladie
alors ce soir je me concerne il dit ouah
ouah bourg histoire noire va qui porte
une cravate
oh ça va quoi honnêtement un but de
notre sérieux on a tellement
l'impression poulet important dans
l'existence que l'idée de notre bord
voire plus
complètement donc si vous voulez c'est
très embêtant ça que je vous raconte
depuis maintenant grâce à ses lecteurs
merci ma cage désolé pour rachel avec la
cac
[Applaudissements]
les escrimeurs parce que si tu veux le
contraire c'est quoi les sols je ne sais
pas n'y a pas de profiter de l'instant
vécu ceux pour qui le temps toujours
leur échappe son seul qui puisse
vraiment la vie sociale il s'appelle nos
missions économiques des terres faire le
profit parce la fuite et il esquive
l'instant vécu d'autres auteurs sénèque
nous dit alors que tu penses à l'abord
tu pourra savourer l'instant vécu
sauf que de peu penser à savoir propres
donc tout ce que je vous ai raconté
depuis le début ne sert à rien
sauf qu'il vient une idée et c'est avec
ça que je vais conclure parce qu'ils
passent 40 secondes d'un phare du filet
je verrai les espaces de toujours fait
sauf que peut-être une solution vous
avez depuis le début et avec c'est vrai
que je me dis qu'il ya une espèce de
decaux occurrence kodjo au centre oeuvre
l'abord d'un côté les bills ambitions
l'homme sur mon dan en mission
professionnelle l'ambition économique et
notre ami senna qui nous dit faites
péter ennemi des digues mortalité est
alors maintenant on en finira avec le
monde des affaires avec l'audition et on
n'arrive pas l'appeler des idées et
l'immortalité de na'vis palabres renvoyé
de ça et comme une concurrente leader de
l'autre sens bien dans l'autre sens soit
on a tendance à dire comme on n'arrive
pas à retirer de l'admettre les gens
malades
ils sont élus à cause de vous on
n'arrive pas à le retirer de la date
qu'ils sont immortels
et comme la ruelle des gens qui se
croient immortels ya un accaparement il
ya une propriété il ya une volonté de
posséder le monde à deux fous de
posséder l'instant ce qu'on peut faire
c'est attaquer la possession de toujours
dans un souci thérapeutique et canadien
ni mal il super mal à son ambition se
réaliser son président ou superman
on n'arrivera pas à retirer rang de
l'idh et d'immortalité 3 le mec il a été
lui trouver ce qui est rare de la
pyramide du louvre la bordure diebold
voiture à l'arrêt l'acteur on écoute les
mortalités x avec par contre peut-être
qu'on peut le soigner en essayant de
l'aider un petit peu à en finir avec la
possession du monde tu me suis là
peut-être que thérapie engagé tué en
deux mots à la thérapie c'est quoi bah
si tu veux pour qu'ils arrivent à être
propriétaire pour l'instant il faut
qu'il cesse d'être propriétaire du
gourdin way
pour la presse on va les aider à être
propriétaire l'instant il va nous les
déposséder du bon ben je sais pas si je
vous voyez où je veux en venir
cap george dire hé ben qui sont obsédés
par la mobilité peut des fois
d'accompagner d'autres choses on a la
balle usage par exemple et balkanique
près qu'ils avaient deux marques
je connais des béquilles sont pas deux
pareils peut-être combiner les balkany
on pourra peut-être un peu leur envolée
des baraques ça leur ferait du bien
parce qu'ils seraient alors dépossédé du
monde et dans des poses et du monde
peut-être qu'il pourrait alors devenir
propriétaire de l'instant donc peut-être
pour rendre service à l'avant choisi
pour après qu'elles puissent jouir de
l'instant j'ai pu pour qu'elle puisse
savourer sa vie parce qu'elle est
malheureuse là vont choisir elle très
malheureuse à l'as riespach joueurs de
l'asc ont vécu lettre pour que la
bourgeoisie elle arriva à jouir de
l'instant vécu ce qui serait super ces
projets les uns d'être dépossédé du
monde et peut-être pour les vols un peu
donc peut-être que si on pouvait votre
impôt tout un petit peu les étés leur
porter assistance en étable therapeutics
a peut être commencé déjà pas en finir
là vers une propriété en finir avec le
vin à cause de poivre vous êtes bourg
puisse leur maladie mentale
j'insiste là dessus si on pouvait tout
supporter ça pour tout alors vous êtes
passés de la valeur de la propriété la
valeur du zinc pour les abonnements si
on pouvait vraiment une bonne fois pour
toutes engagées la jeunesse que vous
êtes à passer le bac gris ac vols et
cambriolages de maisons bourgeoises
sauvette alternative crédible à l'heure
du choix
d'abord à la crise des marchés d'autre
part alors permettra à ces valeureux
bourgeois d'être guéri de l'assurance
qu'ils ont existé je conversais
[Applaudissements]